Este problema nos dice,
si "x" gato "y" es igual a "x" más "3y"
y "x" estrellita "y"
es igual a "4x" cuadrada menos "y" cuadrada
encuentra el valor de
-2 estrella con 3 gato menos 1,
¿va?
Entonces nos definen un par de operaciones
y nos piden encontrar la composición
evaluada en ciertos números.
Vamos a hacerlo.
Como aquí tenemos un paréntesis tenemos que empezar con esta operación,
con 3 gato menos 1.
Entonces déjame hacerla de este lado,
3 gato menos 1,
muy bien,
entonces aquí tenemos la definición de gato.
dice cada "x" vale 3, cada "y" vale -1,
y hay que hacerle estas operaciones.
Entonces "x" es 3, nos quedaría,
3 más 3 por "y",
3 por "y" que es -1.
Y esto es igual a 3 menos 3,
que es igual a 0.
Muy bien, entonces aquí tenemos un 0,
sale y vale,
nos queda -2 estrella 0, ¿va?
déjame marcarlo con color azul...
y con color morado...
Entonces,
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es -2,
-2
estrella
con 0...
estrella con 0.
Sale y vale, entonces ahora vamos
a la definición de estrella para ver qué nos queda.
Aquí en la definición de estrella dice,
voy a poner este 4, voy a poner este elevar al cuadrado, voy a restar..
aquí ahorita pongo "y"
y tengo que elevar al cuadrado,
entonces deje los espacios estratégicos
para poner "x" y "y",
"x" vale -2,
entonces aquí tengo que poner -2.
Y aquí tengo que poner "y"
para elevarlo al cuadrado y "y" vale 0,
entonces sería así, ¿vale?
Entonces es 4 por -2 al cuadrado
menos 0 al cuadrado,
muy bien,
vamos a ver que nos queda,
-2 al cuadrado es 4,
nos quedaría 4 por 4...
4 por 4...
y a eso tenemos que restarle 0 al cuadrado,
o sea tenemos que restarle 0,
menos 0,
y esto de aquí nos da 4 por 4 = 16
16,
y ya no hay que restar nada,
porque restar 0 no es hacer nada.
Entonces la expresión que nos piden aquí,
es igual a 16.